un direct c'est cet afflux massif de
réfugiés est les pays voisins de
l'ukraine leur ont ouvert leurs portes
dès le début de cette guerre ils sont
désormais plus de trois millions de
réfugiés à avoir fui l'ukraine selon les
derniers chiffres communiqués ce matin
par l'onu près du tiers de ces déplacés
sont selon denis celle des enfants un
petit ukrainien est contraint de quitter
son pays chaque seconde selon
l'organisation on va retrouver tout de
suite notre envoyé spécial à la
frontière polonaise emmanuel chaze
emmanuel bonjour quelle est la situation
où vous vous trouvez
eh bien écoutez je me retrouve ici à
rêver né à la frontière entre l'ukraine
et la pologne j'étais déjà il ya un peu
plus de deux semaines maintenant et la
situation d'un côté n'a pas changé
puisque les personnes continuent
d'arriver des centaines par jour et de
l'autre c'est quand même un peu
améliorée d'un point de vue humanitaire
puisque vous pouvez le voir derrière moi
il ya des structures des structures
encore un peu sommaire mais des
structures qui sont bien mises en place
il ya cette tente un peu plus loin
derrière moi qui n'étais pas là il ya
quinze jours les personnes qui arrivent
ici donc c'est un passage de voitures 1
c'est pas un passage où les piétons
peuvent franchir la frontière les gens
peuvent prendre un premier arrêt ici
avant de continuer leur travail leur
voyage par dont ils peuvent ils peuvent
s'arrêter un instant pour savoir un peu
comment ça va se passer pour eux parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes qui une
fois la france la frontière franchie ne
savent pas ce qui les attend ne savent
pas où aller ne savent pas comment ça va
se passer pour eux au niveau du travail
au niveau du logement et puis la plupart
des gens évidemment qui viennent
d'ukraine n'ont pas pour but de rester
ni en pologne ni dans les pays voisins
ils ont ils envisagent cet exil comme un
exil temporaire est qu'ils arrivent
souvent plus choqué encore que ce que
j'ai pu voir il ya deux semaines puisque
maintenant la population réfugiée que
l'on voit arriver vient principalement
des villes qui ont déjà été bombardée
donc une population réfugiée un peu plus
traumatisées ça chaque jour et comme
vous le soulignez énormément d'enfants
leur valent dans la vaste majorité les
réfugiés qui viennent ce sont des femmes
d enfants des personnes âgées les seuls
quasiment autorisé rappelons le a quitté
l'ukraine l'essentiel des hommes étant
mobilisé les forces vives comme on dit
un mot peut-être emmanuel j'indiquais ce
chiffre communiqué par l'onu plus de
trois millions de réfugiés à ceux à ce
jour les autorités polonaises font elles
face à cet afflux
écoutez ziff en face tant bien que mal
j'ai envie de vous dire 1,7 million des
réfugiés venus d'ukraine a trouvé refuge
ici en pologne il y à des structures qui
sont mis en place des infrastructures
qui sont mises en place les écoles sont
ouvertes pour servir de centre
d'hébergement d'urgence hier je parlais
à un représentant de la ville de chez
michel qui se trouve à environ 40
minutes de voiture d'ici qui me disait
sa ville de 50000 habitants peut
accueillir dans le meilleur des cas 2000
personnes sofcap chez michel depuis le
début de conflit il y avait cinquante
mille personnes qui arrivaient par jour
cette semaine c'est un peu plus calme at
il dit avec entre guillemets seulement
vingt mille personnes arrivant chaque
jour pour cette seule ville de chez
michel donc les autorités polonaises
faux face elles sont également aidés en
cela par beaucoup des ong des ong
polonaise évidemment mais également des
ong venues du monde entier elle reste
que la pologne notamment le maire de
varsovie varsovie qui accueille 10 % de
ces indiens du 7 millions de réfugiés
est-ce que la pologne en appel à l'aide
internationale pour tenter de gérer
cette crise humanitaire qui se déroule
sur son territoire